one of the best things about the mcu is
getting to see your favorite characters
team up totally like ant-man and the
wasp for iron man and war machine or
rocket and groot today we're going to
play a rapid-fire game of choose your
team up featuring marvel's newest
superhero xiang-chi you ready let's go
aliens are invading new york i'm gonna
go with captain marvel who does he grab
a slice with uh tony stark busting up an
enemy bunker together with hulk karaoke
night who's he harmonizing with you
going up against stannis who would he
want to be next to him iron man you're
running late to a friend's party who
would you call to give you a lift to get
there on time you we make a good team
all right last one enjoy riding through
san francisco in a sweet new ride i'm
trying you borrowed from someone way
nicer than you uh borrowed get it i'll
go slow
don't miss the mcu's newest hero and his
bff katie in marvel studios shangxi and
the legend of the ten rings hitting
theaters september 3rd